[MUSIC PLAYING]
TIMOTHY JORDAN: Hello.
I'm Timothy Jordan and
welcome to the Developer Show.
Another episode right
here from Google I/O 2016.
Right now we're going to talk
to Rich from the material design
team.
[MUSIC PLAYING]
Rich, thank you
for taking the time
to talk to us about
material design.
RICHARD FULCHER: It's
what we love, right?
TIMOTHY JORDAN: So
this booth-- all you're
doing-- all of Google I/O
is material design reviews.
Tell me what the deal is there.
RICHARD FULCHER: No.
It's a great opportunity for
us to have developers come in,
talk about their apps, their
experiences, what questions
they have, what issues
they're facing in design,
and in particular, how they're
applying material design
to everything they're doing.
TIMOTHY JORDAN: Great.
So give me the quick
synopsis-- what
is material design, for
the handful of you that
don't know yet.
RICHARD FULCHER:
So material design
is a design language
that's designed
to be incredibly responsive.
It can work on a
variety of platforms.
It can support a large number
of brands, any brand, not just
Google's brand.
And it is kind of
future looking.
It makes heavy use of
motion design and animation
to bring the best possible
experience to all of our users.
TIMOTHY JORDAN:
And it's beautiful.
You probably needed
me to say that.
But I think it's beautiful.
But a point you made that
I think is really key
and one of the reasons why
these reviews are so helpful
is the material design is so
flexible in its application--
that your brand can really shine
through as the primary feeling.
And yet you can still build
that on to the scaffolding
of material design.
RICHARD FULCHER: Yeah.
I think a lot of people
look at material.
And they look at a lot of
the great apps from Google
and naturally think, oh, that's
what material looks like.
But more and more we're
seeing just fantastic apps
that are using material from
brands that are not Google
and that really strongly
express the brand's identity,
the characteristics,
the kind of emotional
feel you want to
have out of a brand,
but still have that
foundational layer of material.
So you're getting
all the benefits
of kind of good behaviors,
of accessible, intelligent,
obvious components,
and things like that.
TIMOTHY JORDAN: Awesome.
[MUSIC PLAYING]
What are some of the resources
that they can visit online
to get some of the same reviews?
RICHARD FULCHER: Oh, the best
place to start is just go
to google.com/design.
That's where you can get the
material design guidelines is
some of what's there.
But there's also a
lot of other content.
There's tools like the icon
library, like the resizer.
TIMOTHY JORDAN: Oh, cool.
Rich, thanks for
taking the time.
RICHARD FULCHER: My pleasure.
Thanks.
[MUSIC PLAYING]